all of this comes at a time when the
nation's numbers
are so huge you mentioned the nearly
1900
total for just yesterday of people who
passed away
these are people that were losing this
feels like it did
almost in the beginning but it certainly
feels like
what they told us to expect and you see
governors now talking more about masks
here in new jersey they are this is a
separate conversation
for so many people to politics but i
just add all that in
because you know politics invades
everything yeah
well and the virus invades everything
right you know emily um you know
government officials are trying to
trying to make these decisions
about lockdowns but we also know now a
lot more about the consequences
of lockdowns whether it's miss medical
appointments whether
it's suicide rates being up the va just
came out with a report today showing
that veteran suicides are up
and the military has been struggling
with how to deal with the isolation as a
result of this disease
so where are we on you know going back
to lockdowns
while balancing the consequences of
keeping people from working
that's exactly right katie and that's
why this is so heartbreaking
because in the overall analysis there's
a failure from my opinion to
to really capture and to weigh in an
equal manner
all of those other effects that are
happening that you mentioned that are
that are like i said so heartbreaking
and i try to stay away from hyperbole
but
the the notion of a second economic
lockdown is frankly terrifying to me and
just to focus on economics for a quick
moment you know over 90 percent of
businesses
in this country are small and medium
sized over a hundred thousand
have shuttered permanently because of
the first coveted lockdown and one in
five
business owners estimate that they won't
make it to the end of the year
that's without a second lockdown we
spoke in the last block about african
americans in this country they are being
disproportionately affected
as active black owned small businesses
were down 41
in that first lockdown that is twice the
rate of others
these are real statistics that have
consequences for people's livelihoods
and staying alive and putting food on
the table and look i just speak for my
own family
when i say that we live payroll to
payroll with our small business and
that's the one that made it because the
other one
didn't survive the first lockdown yeah
well we got to go but joe biden said he
was not going to do this so we'll see if
he takes his advice
his advisor's advice